This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。“百分之二”。这是指在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及构建抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。名字就是数字 2，请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在 Look Back at it 播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和说是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方订阅 Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套精神盔甲。它向世界传递的信号是，你不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不。意味着你就必须这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《以艰难的方式学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同名女子。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple 播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology.
我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时面临的最大改变、重要时刻和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, on listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Starting a business during this decade, starting a successful business in this decade is a big goal that I know a lot of you guys have. I so often get requests for advice on this or to bring somebody on who can give us some no bullshit, straight shooting advice on what it takes, how to formulate an idea, how to execute an idea, how to handle money, investment stuff. Today I am so lucky to have that somebody on the podcast who can talk us through all of these things.
大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目，当然，我们今天要剖析的是二十多岁的心理学。在这个十年里创业，在这个十年里建立一个成功的事业，是我知道你们很多人都有的一个宏伟目标。我经常收到大家的请求，希望我能给出这方面的建议，或者请一位能够提供毫不矫情、直截了当的建议的嘉宾，告诉我们创业需要什么、如何构思一个想法、如何执行一个想法、如何处理资金和投资等相关事宜。今天，我非常幸运地邀请到了这样一位嘉宾来到播客中，她将为我们详细讲解所有这些事情。
Brittany Saunders is the founder and CEO of Fate the label. It is an iconic Australian clothing brand, iconic. that has exploded in recent years and she started this business in her 20s. I'm so excited to have her on and to hear her story. Brittany Saunders, welcome to the psychology of your 20s. Thanks for having me, Gemma. I feel like your voice is so calming. Do people say that to you?
布列塔尼·桑德斯是 Fate the label 的创始人兼首席执行官。这是一个标志性的澳大利亚服装品牌，标志性的品牌。近年来发展迅猛，而她在二十多岁时就创立了这家企业。我非常高兴能邀请她来做客并听听她的故事。布列塔尼·桑德斯，欢迎来到《你二十多岁的心理学》。谢谢邀请我，杰玛。我觉得你的声音太让人平静了。人们经常对你这么说吗？
They do, they do. I don't know what it is, though, because I find my voice really irritating. But I feel like I need to match the way that you talk so that we can. No, I'm not going to do that. Because my voice is like naturally very loud and then you're being really calm. So I'm like, I think I need to be calm. Yeah, I hear it funny. Well, I was saying, look, I love having to you before this.
他们会的，会的。不过我也不知道为什么，因为我自己觉得我的声音真的很烦人。但我觉得我需要配合你说话的方式，这样我们才能。不，我才不这么做呢。因为我的声音天生就很响亮，而你又表现得非常冷静。所以我想，我觉得我也得冷静点。是的，我觉得挺搞笑的。嗯，我刚才想说，看，我之前就挺喜欢邀请你的。
I was like, I love having another Australian on the podcast. I feel like you need to get some more on. I know, I do. I do. I do a lot, but like just this year, I just haven't happened. That's kind of cool, though, if you're mixing it up and getting people from all over the world. But I feel like people always say, oh my God, yeah, like you don't have a strong Australian accent. And I'm like, I think I do.
我当时就想，我很喜欢在播客里再邀请一个澳大利亚人。我觉得你应该多请几个来。我知道，我得这么做。我应该的。我做过很多，但就是今年，一直没能排上。不过，如果你能换换风格，邀请来自世界各地的人，其实也挺酷的。但我觉得人们总是会说：“哦天哪，对啊，你没有很浓的澳大利亚口音。”然后我就想，我觉得我有啊。
But hearing your accent. Mine's pretty strong. Yeah, and I love it. I'm like, oh, maybe I should really, maybe I should get back to my roots. Yeah, how the fuck I am. I really get into it, you know, like really put us. We can talk like that the rest of the episode. And everybody turns it off.
但听到你的口音。我的口音挺重的。对，而且我很喜欢。我就会想，哦，也许我真的应该，也许我应该回归我的根源。对，我他妈到底是谁啊。我真的投入进去了，你知道的，就像真的把我们。我们可以用这种口音聊完剩下的节目。然后所有人都把节目关了。
And the downloads are gone. Yeah. Okay, well, tell me a little bit about your story. I feel like I'm going to get ahead of myself. What did you want to be when you grew up? Where did you grow up? What's like the history of Brit? So I am from Newcastle, which if you're not familiar or anyone listening,
然后下载量就没了。好吧，那么，跟我讲讲你的故事吧。我觉得我有点操之过急了。你小时候长大想做什么？你在哪里长大的？布里特的过去是怎样的？所以我来自纽卡斯尔，如果你不熟悉或者任何听众不熟悉的话，
it's a little regional city two hours north of Sydney, or maybe two and a half, depending on what part of Sydney you're coming from. is massive. So I'm a born and bred newie gal. I lived like around Australia in my late teens and early 20s. And a long story short is in high school, I discovered this website called YouTube and I thought that looks fun. So I just started that as a hobby and did it all throughout high school. I dropped out of school when I was 16 to be a waitress because I hated being at school. I had no interest in school. I wasn't bad in school. Like, I was actually pretty good and especially like in year 10, like at the subjects that I chose. But I just like had no interest
它是一个距离悉尼以北两小时车程的小型区域性城市，或者大概两个半小时，这取决于你从悉尼的哪个部分出发。规模很大。所以我是一个土生土长的纽卡斯尔女孩。我在十八九岁到二十岁出头的时候在澳大利亚各地生活过。长话短说，就是在高中时，我发现了 YouTube 这个网站，我觉得这看起来挺有意思的。所以我只是把这当作一个爱好开始做，并且在整个高中时期一直坚持着。我16岁时辍学去当了一名女服务生，因为我讨厌在学校呆着。我对学校毫无兴趣。我在学校表现并不差。实际上，我还算挺不错的，特别是在10年级的时候，比如我选择的那些科目。但我就是毫无兴趣
in being there. And I feel like from a young age, like when you're a teenager, you're kind of told by all of your teachers and the careers advisor, you know, you've got to figure out what it is that you want to do for the rest of your life right now. And it's like, I am 15. I don't even have a lobe to develop. Like, it's not there. I just so vividly remember being in like year nine and going into year 10. And I was a year young for my year as well. So I was going into year 10 and, you know, you'd have, like we got introduced to the school
呆在那里。我觉得从小时候起，当你还是个青少年时，你所有的老师和职业顾问都会告诉你，你知道的，你现在必须弄清楚自己这辈子到底想做什么。这就像，我才15岁。我甚至连大脑额叶都还没发育好呢。它根本就不在那儿。我非常清晰地记得，在念9年级准备升10年级的时候。而且我在同年级里年龄偏小。所以我当时正要升入10年级，然后你知道的，学校会给我们安排
careers advisor. Yeah. And they used to make you do this quiz. Did you do this quiz? Like this, it was like 10 pages and it was like, what are you going to be when you grow up? Yeah. And it's like, how do I know? And I remember back then thinking, I have no idea what I want to do.
职业顾问。是的。他们会让你做这样一份测试。你做过这种测试吗？它大概有10页，上面写着：你长大后想做什么？是的。这让我怎么知道啊？我记得当时心想，我根本不知道自己想做什么。
like I had no idea. I had no interest in the idea of going to uni. And I remember all my friends in school at the time, like they knew that they were going to go to uni and become a nurse because their mum was a nurse or whatever. Or they want to be a teacher. And I remember going to the careers advisor and thinking and saying, I don't know what it is that I want to do. And something really random. At one point, he was trying to sell the idea to me of going into the Army Reserves. Oh my God, I just got chills because that happened to me as well. Did it? I genuinely just got chills.
就像我完全没有头绪。我对去上大学这件事一点兴趣也没有。我记得当时学校里的所有朋友，他们都知道自己要上大学，然后去当护士，因为他们妈妈是护士之类的。或者他们想当老师。我记得我去找职业顾问时心里想着并对他说，我不知道自己想做什么。然后发生了一件很随机的事。有一阶段，他一直在向我推销去预备役部队（Army Reserves）的想法。哦天哪，我刚起了一身鸡皮疙瘩，因为我也遇到过这种事。真的吗？我真的起鸡皮疙瘩了。
I'm not even joking. You got goosebumps. I got goosebumps because that happened to me. They were like, you should really join the Army Reservoir. And I was like, what part of me makes you think that that's a good idea? I know. I'm not this young girl. Like, no clue.
我真没开玩笑。你起鸡疙瘩了。我起鸡皮疙瘩了，因为这事也发生在我身上。他们当时说：“你真应该加入陆军预备役。”然后我就想：“我身上的哪一点让你觉得这是个好主意？”我知道。我当时还是个懵懂的小女孩。完全没有头绪。
And I don't know if they were like incentivised. Maybe that's what I was just thinking. He had like all brochures and pamphlets and he's handing them all to me and I was like, oh, okay, maybe this is what I want to do. So then I went to some like career day at like the Army Resort. Like at Advert. Like an ad phone or something. Yeah. And so, like, I just had no idea.
而且我不知道他们是不是有什么业绩提成。也许我刚才就是这么想的。他拿出了所有的宣传册和小册子，全塞给我，然后我就想，哦，好吧，也许这就是我想做的事。于是我就去参加了陆军预备役的某个职业日。就像广告展会那样。类似于招聘会什么的。对。所以，我当时完全没有头绪。
I applied for a couple of, like, hair dressing apprenticeships. Because you know how, like, when you get to year 10, everyone's dropping out to go become a beauty therapist or a hairdresser? I was like, yeah, okay, that's what I want to do. That sounds great. Yeah. So I went and did a couple of trials to become a first year apprentice. How many hours did you work when you were doing that?
我申请了几家美发学徒的工作。因为你知道的，当升到10年级时，每个人都退学去当美容师或美发师？我就想：“行吧，好吧，这就是我想做的。听起来不错。”对。所以我去参加了几个成为第一年学徒的试工。你当时做这个工作时每周工作多少小时？
Just so many, right? Yeah, I think, like, one trial was a week. Unpaid. Unpaid? Yeah, back then. I think you have to get paid. I don't even know. I honestly wouldn't put it past them.
简直多得离谱，对吧？对，我想，其中有一个试工是一周。无薪的。无薪？对，那时候。我想现在你必须得拿工资了。我甚至都不知道。说实话，我也不会觉得他们干不出不付工资的事。
Back then, yeah, I remember I got paid nothing. And all I did was sweep floors and make cups of tea for a week at this one place. Then they handed me like a big pack of shampoo and conditioner at the end. They said, sorry, you didn't get the job. I'm there like crying. But looking back now, like I'm so glad that never worked out. So, yeah, dropped out when I was just waitressing in Newcastle, was working on my YouTube channel.
那时候，是的，我记得我一分钱也没拿到。在那里的一个星期里，我做的事就是扫地和泡茶。然后他们在最后递给我一大包洗发水和护士素。他们说：“对不起，你没有被录用。”我在那儿哭。但现在回想起来，我真庆幸当时没成功。所以，是的，我辍学了，当时在纽卡斯尔当服务员，同时在经营我的 YouTube 频道。
I had over 20 different jobs in my teens and into my early 20s and worked in every industry because I was just trying to. to figure out what it was that I wanted to do, doing the YouTube. And then throughout those late teen years, I also dabbled in what I didn't know at the time were businesses. But I just thought that were like little hobbies or something, you know? So I did like mobile spray tans. And then I set up a little spray tan business at home because I had this like lawn mower storage underneath my house. That's very smart. It was like on a sloping block. And then you knew how they'd be like the wooden door and then like a brick room under the back of the house. Yeah, yeah, yeah. This is a very
我在十几岁到二十岁出头的时候换过20多份不同的工作，在各个行业都干过，因为我当时只是在试图。弄清楚自己到底想做什么，同时做着 YouTube。然后在我青少年时期的后期，我还涉足了一些当时我并不知道那其实是生意的领域。我只是觉得那是些小爱好什么的，你知道吗？所以我做过移动喷雾美黑。然后我在家里布置了一个小型喷雾美黑业务，因为我家底下有一个存放割草机的储藏间。这太聪明了。那是在一个斜坡地块上。然后你懂的，那种有木门，后面房子底下是个砖砌房间的结构。对，对，对。这是一个非常
Australian thing. Yeah. I don't know why. Yeah, I used to always walk past these and be like, there are children trapped in there. Yeah. You know what I mean? I was in there doing pupping little spray tans. So I set up a business there. I would have been 17 or 18 at the time, taught myself how to do makeup and was doing a bit of makeup on YouTube and stuff. So then I was doing freelance makeup. Um, tried decorating and selling iPhone cases on Facebook. There were just so many things that I did in those early developmental years that I just thought were like fun. You know, I never really made any money out of them. And then my YouTube kind of really kicked off. Do you remember the video? It wasn't a video. It's because I'd been doing it for years,
澳大利亚式的特色。对。我不知道为什么。是的，我以前总是路过这些地方，心想：里面是不是关着小孩子？你知道我的意思吗？我就在里面做那些小小的喷雾美黑。所以我当时在那里建立了一项业务。我当时大概17或18岁，自学了化妆，并在 YouTube 上做一些美妆内容之类的。然后我就开始做自由化妆师。嗯，尝试在 Facebook 上装饰并出售 iPhone 手机壳。在那些早期的发展岁月里，我做了太多太多的事情，而我当时只觉得它们很有趣。你知道的，我从来没有真正从中赚到什么钱。然后我的 YouTube 频道就开始真正火起来了。你还记得那个视频吗？那不是一个视频。因为我已经做这行好几年了，
like from ages of 15 up until 21, which is how many years? Six. Like six years. So from, yeah, about 15 years old to 21, I went from zero subscribers to 80,000. And back then, back to the then that was kind of like a big deal. That's still a big deal. Yeah. Back then I remember like the OG YouTube days. Yeah. And so to have 80,000 subscribers was like kind of a big deal and I was 21 and I was working full time in an admin role in Newcastle. And I was just earning like a little bit of money off the ads. And then this is when Instagram had come out as well. So I had maybe 20,000 followers on Instagram. And I started getting paid like $50 for an Instagram post, $100 for an Instagram post. you know, just like holding up a protein powder next to my face or whatever.
从15岁一直到21岁，这总共是多少年？六年。差不多六年。所以从，是的，大约15岁到21岁，我的订阅者从零增长到了8万。在那个年代，在那个时候，这其实已经算是一件挺了不起的事了。现在这仍然是一件大事。对。那时我记得那是 YouTube 的早期黄金时代。对。所以拥有8万订阅者在当时算是一件蛮大的事，我当时21岁，在纽卡斯尔全职做一份行政工作。我靠广告赚了一点点钱。然后这时候 Instagram 也面世了。所以我在 Instagram 上可能有了2万粉丝。我开始因为一条 Instagram 帖子赚到50美元、100美元，
Do you remember how, like, how low energy it used to be? Yes, I would. Adds back then? It was like, um, one brand that I worked with back then was protein world. I don't know if you remember that. And they had like this slender shake or some shit. Oh, classic. It was in like the skinny me tea days.
你知道的，就是拿着一罐蛋白粉放在脸旁边之类的。你还记得以前那种，能量有多低吗？是的，我记得。以前的广告？就像是，嗯，我当时合作过的一个品牌是 Protein World。我不知道你还记不记得。他们有一款叫 Slender Shake 的奶昔还是什么的。哦，经典啊。那是在瘦身茶（skinny me tea）盛行的时期。
Yeah, I was just thinking that. And I'm pretty sure I did like one of those detox tea post too. And like you would literally get sent the product and I would just hold it next to my face and smile in a selfie and put that on Instagram and I'd get like $150. And so that was like the. I'll do it. Yeah. So that was the start of me, like, earning money through Instagram and obviously making a bit
我刚刚也在想这个。而且我敢肯定我也发过那种排毒茶的帖子。基本上就是品牌会把产品寄给你，然后我拿着它放在脸旁边对着自拍笑，把照片发到 Instagram 上，就能拿到大约150美元。所以这就是那个。我愿意干。对。所以这就是我开始通过 Instagram 赚钱，并且显然从 YouTube 广告中赚了一点钱的开端。
off the YouTube ads. And, again, long story short, but at the age of 21, I kind of looked at the money that I was earning through my YouTube and Instagram, which was nothing. And I was living in a sharehouse at the time with, like, three other people, paying like $100 a week rent, $60 on petrol, $50 on groceries back then. I remember working out, okay, this is how much it costs me to live. I'm going to quit my full-time job and try to make this YouTube thing, my full-time job. What's the worst that's going to happen?
总之，长话短说，在21岁的时候，我大致看了一下我通过 YouTube 和 Instagram 赚到的钱，其实根本没多少。当时我和另外三个人合租一套房子，每周房租大约100美元，汽油费60美元，当时的杂货费大概50美元。我记得当时算了一笔账，好吧，这就是我的生活成本。我要辞掉全职工作，试着把做 YouTube 当成我的全职工作。最糟糕的情况会是什么呢？
Yeah. If this doesn't work out, I will just go and get another job because I've had over 20 by this point. Yeah. And I've been working for myself ever since. So it's been 11 years now. Wow. I'm 32 now. And obviously the YouTube then absolutely boomed.
对。如果这行不通，我就再去换一份工作，因为到这个时候我已经做过20多份工作了。对。从那以后，我就一直是自己给自己打工。所以到现在已经11年了。哇。我现在32岁了。很明显，当时的 YouTube 随后绝对是迎来了大爆发。
In three years, that 80,000 subscribers I built. to a million and then I was like a full-blown influencer in that first like wave of influences in Australia which was so surreal looking back on now it just doesn't feel real what was the coolest thing you got to do whilst you were because to break the fourth wall like I was how much younger than you're I'm seven years younger yeah so I remember being in high school so you were a little teenager I was a teenager and I knew who you were yeah you were like this is the you were like the one of like the it girls yeah like the Aussie girls but like the Bogan one oh well because that was in the era of like beauty guru and i know there's all these others like um there was that girl
在三年时间里，我苦心经营的8万订阅者增长到了100万，然后我就成了澳大利亚第一代网红浪潮中的名副其实的网红，现在回想起来真的太超现实了，感觉一点都不真实。当你还在做网红的时候，做过的最酷的事情是什么？因为为了打破第四堵墙——老实说，我比你小多少？我比你小七岁。对，所以我记得我上高中时。所以你还是个小青少年。我当时是个青少年，而且我知道你是谁。对，你就像是那种，你是那种“it girl”之一。对，就像那些澳洲女孩，但却是那个有点“土气（Bogan）”的女孩哦，因为那是美妆博主盛行的时代，我知道还有其他很多人，比如……
los curtis cloy more yes oh my gosh sharnie grimmin chloe zep and then there was me going how the fuck are you and then everyone would go she's the bogan one oh my god i just always stayed true to myself yeah you totally did um the most surreal thing back then probably would have just been all the opportunities of traveling with brands, like getting taken to Spain with Nas Cosmetics for a global brand trip when they were launching a new mascara. Just going all the way to Spain for three days, just for them to launch the red climax mascara. Which, by the way, but that's kind of iconic.
露丝·柯蒂斯、克洛伊·莫尔。是的，哦天哪，莎妮·格里明、克洛伊·泽普，然后还有我，说着“你他妈到底是谁啊”，接着每个人都会说“她就是那个土里土气的女孩”。天哪，我一直忠于自我。对，你完全做到了。嗯，当时最超现实的事情，可能就是所有那些跟着品牌旅行的机会，比如跟着 Nars 化妆品公司去西班牙参加全球品牌之旅，当时他们在推出一款新的睫毛膏。为了让他们推出红色高潮睫毛膏（red climax mascara），一路大老远飞去西班牙待三天。顺便说一句，不过这确实挺具有标志性的。
Yeah. I have that mascara. Yes, I still have it. We went to the launch of that. You know what? This is just this whole economy where people think that like influencing and like content creation is like that's not a real job. It's like no, no, no.
对。我有那款睫毛膏。是的，我至今还留着。我们去参加了那个发布产品的活动。你知道吗？这就是整个经济现象，人们觉得当网红和做内容创作不是一份真正的工作。其实不然，真的不是。
Like the money behind these industries is billions and billions and billions of dollars. Yeah, exactly right. And it's changed a lot since back then when I did all of that. Like the industry as a whole is completely different. And I guess back then we were lucky because what we were doing was aspirational. It was like, oh my God, did you see Brittany got to go on the trip and with Tart trips, you know, to Hayman Island? Oh my God, I remember those.
这些行业背后的资金规模是几十亿、几百亿甚至数千亿美元。对，完全正确。而且自从我当年做这些事情以来，它已经发生了很大的变化。整个行业已经完全不同了。我想我们当年很幸运，因为我们所做的事情是令人向往的。就像是，“哦天哪，你看到了吗，布里塔尼去旅行了，和 Tarte 品牌一起去海曼岛了？”哦天哪，我记得那些。
The tart trips. It was like, cool, because it was new, and it was this whole new era of influencing. And then influences got picked, and then everyone was almost like excited. Like, oh, this is so cool. Whereas it's been so interesting now to have been around for so long where a brand will do a brand trip now. And people go, this is tone deaf. You know, like they're sick of it. They're like, this is too on a, did you see this thing the other day?
Tarte 的品牌旅行。这感觉很酷，因为它是崭新的，这是网红行业的全新时代。然后网红被选中了，每个人几乎都感到很兴奋。就像，“哦，这太酷了。”然而，现在情况变得很有趣，在这个行业待了这么久之后，当一个品牌现在组织品牌旅行时。人们会说：“这太不接地气了。”你知道的，他们已经看腻了。他们会觉得：“这太做作了，你看到前几天那个事了吗？”
It was like having a life core where it's like, I saw this post about this the other day where it's like, we don't want unattainable things. Like people are moving back to like the authentic. Yeah. Like content of like this is unattainable. Yeah. People love to see just everyday life. People go into work and then documenting that.
就像是有一种叫 life core 的东西，我前几天看到一个关于这个的帖子，上面说：“我们不想要高不可攀的东西。”就像人们正在回归真实。对。那种内容是：“这太高不可攀了。”对。人们喜欢看日常生活。人们去上班，然后把这些记录下来。
But I guess I feel lucky that I was in that kind of first wave of influences in Australia because it was new and it was cool. And everyone was like, oh my God, this is amazing goals. Okay. So this is this like amazing journey. You've been on a fun journey. Like when did you decide to quit influencers? and when did you first get the idea for fate?
但我想我还是觉得自己很幸运，能赶上澳大利亚的第一代网红浪潮，因为它当时很新鲜，很酷。每个人都觉得：“哦天哪，这太棒了，简直是人生目标。”好了。所以这是一段非常惊艳的旅程。你经历了一段有趣的旅程。你是什么时候决定不再做纯网红的？又是何时萌生了创立 Fate 的想法？
So the idea of fate came about probably around the age of 23 to 24 and people will always look at fate now and go, oh, like what was your business plan? Like you must have had, you know, all of your ducks in a road to like looking at what fate is today. But I always say when I started fate, it was much like when I started the spray tans under my house. It was not this big grand plan.
所以关于 Fate 的想法大约是在我23、24岁左右萌生的，人们现在看到 Fate 时总是会问：“哦，你当时的商业计划是什么？你肯定把所有事情都筹划好了，才能成就今天的 Fate。”但我总是说，当我创立 Fate 时，这很像我在家底下做喷雾美黑的时候。这根本不是什么宏大的计划。
I dabbled in lots of other small little businesses. I think the only difference with fate and going into the world of e-com was I was a little bit older. I was still very young. But I also had an audience. Yeah. So I knew obviously, well, I've got all these people following me. I've got these YouTube subscribers of over a million.
我涉足过许多其他的小型业务。我想 Fate 和进入电商世界唯一的不同之处在于，我当时稍微大了一岁。我依然非常年轻。但我也拥有了一批受众。对。所以我很清楚，我有这么多人关注我。我有超过一百万的 YouTube 订阅者。
I've got potential customers here. So that was the biggest difference for me. And it was definitely an advantage. But that doesn't mean that I, I knew how to run a business. It didn't mean that I knew how to build one from scratch or scale one or sustain it, but I had that audience. And it was very much a, I'm like a very think of it and do it person.
我这里有潜在的客户。所以这对我来说是最大的优势。这绝对是一个优势。但这并不意味着我。我知道如何经营一家公司。这并不意味着我知道如何从零开始建立一个品牌，或者如何扩大规模或维持它，但我拥有那些受众。而且这非常像是一种，我是一个“想到就去做”的人。
Like I'll lay in bed at night and then have an idea pop into my head and I'll go, AJ, I've got this idea. And then I'll start doing it tomorrow. It was very much the same when it came to fate. It was just learning everything myself. And I think like I had the experience of working with so many, I work with so many brands, like in my early 20s. I had ongoing partnerships where brands were paying me every month to do, you know,
我晚上躺在床上，脑子里突然冒出一个想法，然后我就会对 AJ 说：“AJ，我有个想法。”接着我第二天就开始干了。当涉及到 Fate 时，情况也是如此。这完全是我自己摸索一切。而且我觉得，我有跟这么多品牌合作的经验，在我二十岁出头的时候，我有很多长期的合作关系，品牌每个月付钱给我，让我为他们的产品做……
a post for their products and stories. And so I guess I kind of thought in the back of my mind, why don't I do this but with my own products instead of just always promoting other products. And when I was influencing, I even think back to, you know, when YouTubers would do like a Q&A video. Yes. And it'd be like, send me in your questions and I'll do a Q&A. And then you'd be like, hi, guys, welcome back.
为他们的产品发帖和发限时动态。所以我想我当时脑子里就在想，为什么我不把这个用在我自己的产品上，而不是总去推广别人的产品呢？当我还是一名网红时，我甚至会回想起，你知道的，当 YouTubers 做问答视频的时候。是的。通常会说：“把你们的问题发给我，我来做一个 Q&A。”然后你就会说：“嗨，大家好，欢迎回来。”
I'm going to do a Q&A and then you would get like thousands of comments asking questions. And I remember one common question that I would always get back then was what would you do if you didn't have this YouTube stuff? Like that would always be a question that would come up in my Q&As. And I would always say, and I could probably go back and find one of my old videos, they're all archived, but I would always say, I know that I'm not going to do this forever. I knew that it wasn't sustainable for me to be an influencer forever. I mean, I definitely could. I could still be, you know, a full-blown influencer now, just doing brand deals every day.
“我要做一个 Q&A”，然后你就会收到成千上万条提问的评论。我记得当时我经常听到一个常见问题是：“如果你不做 YouTube 这些东西，你会做什么？”这总会成为我问答环节中出现的一个问题。我总是会说——我大概还能回去翻出我以前的一些视频，它们都存档了——但我总是会说，我知道我不会永远做这个。我知道作为网红对我来说是不可持续的，无法永远做下去。我的意思是，我当然可以。我现在完全可以继续当一个标准的网红，每天只接品牌合作。
But like even back then, like when I was in the peak of the YouTube stuff and like the influencer sponsored posts, like I always knew in the back of my mind, I don't want to do this forever. I felt like I had more that I wanted to achieve or do. I just didn't know what it was. And so when it come to me launching fate, it wasn't this big grand idea. I didn't think I'm going to turn this into a really popular brand and we're going to have all of these sizes. It was very much, I'm just going to start this thing. I hired AJ, who's my partner, his mom's family friend's daughter, to just come and work with me because it was just at my house.
但就像在那时一样，当我处于 YouTube 事业的巅峰时期以及网红赞助帖子的黄金期时，我心里一直很清楚，我不想永远做这个。我觉得我还有更多想要实现或去做的事情。我只是不知道那是什么。所以当我要推出 Fate 时，这并不是什么宏大的构想。我当时并没有想过要把这个品牌变成一个非常受欢迎的品牌，我们要有各种尺码。这很大程度上只是，我只是要开始做这件。我雇用了 AJ——我的伴侣，他妈妈是家庭朋友的女儿——来和我一起工作，因为当时公司就在我家。
Yeah. So I was like, yeah, just come and work with me like two to three days a week and just help me pack the orders and do the customer service and go to the PO box. to get our returns. And so it was very DIY. And AJ, he was an electrician at the time. So he would just, he helped me like set everything up and like, oh, his post accounts and website. I just learned how to build a Shopify website. It was just very DIY. And I didn't see past that moment when I started it. Do you think that was helpful? Yeah. Just to be like, we're just going to make this now? Yeah, 100%. And I think, again, much like how I started my influencer journey, really early. I'm also glad that I started Fate eight years ago because I didn't have all these
对。所以我当时就说：“行吧，你一周来跟我工作两三天，帮我打包订单、做客服，然后去邮政信箱取退货。”所以这非常具有 DIY 风格。而且 AJ 当时是一名电工。所以他只是帮我把所有东西都设置好，比如发货账户和网站。我就是这样自己学会建立一个 Shopify 网站的。这完全是 DIY 的。当我刚开始做的时候，我根本没有看到那么长远的未来。你觉得这有帮助吗？是的。就是那种“我们现在就要把这事干了”的心态？是的，百分之百。而且我觉得，这很像我是如何开启我的网红生涯的一样，非常早。我也很庆幸我在八年前创办了 Fate，因为我当时没有现在创业的人可能会有的那些期望，因为我能想象，对于那些想要涉足电商并建立一个小型 Shopify 商店的人来说，这可能会非常让人不知所措。本集节目不由 Shopify 赞助。我知道，我不能。不，但它们确实很好。对。我们 Fate 就是用 Shopify 的。对。你知道的，如果我是今天才开始，而且像我当年刚创办 Fate 时那样，这还是在小红书、抖音小店这些爆火之前。没有那种东西，你知道的，当时没有人围绕自己的生意去创作内容。我甚至还记得当我刚创立 Fate 时心想，哦，我不知道我是不是能把这个发到我的社交媒体上，因为我不知道我的受众会不会喜欢这个，因为他们想看我的 Kmart 购物开箱（Haul）和Vlog，你知道的，去西田购物中心逛街。是的，Q&A。所以我开始发了一些关于这个的小 YouTube 视频。我从来不展示我家的棚屋，因为那是最初设置总部的地方。我会去楼上的客房。这是我的总部和办公室。但我从来不展示车库，因为我对此感到不好意思。然而现在，在2025年或2026年，如果你在车库里创业，你会把那过程记录得淋漓尽致。
expectations that maybe someone starting a business now would have because I could imagine it would be really overwhelming for, let's say, someone's wanting to get into e-com and start a little Shopify store. This episode is not sponsored by Shopify. I know, I can't. No, but they're just really good. Yeah. We use Shopify for Fate. Yeah. Um, you know, if I was starting today and I, like, when I started Fade, this was before like small business. TikTok. Like there's no such thing as that, you know, people, no one was creating content about their business. And I even remember back then when I started Fate thinking, oh, like, I don't know if I'm going to be able to put this like on my social media because I don't know if my
现在开始创业的人可能会有的期望，因为我可以想象，对于那些想进入电商领域并开一家小Shopify店铺的人来说，这真的会让人不知所措。本期节目没有得到Shopify的赞助。我知道，我不能。不，但他们确实很好。是的。我们为Fate使用Shopify。是的。嗯，你知道，如果我今天开始，而且就像我刚开始做Fate的时候，那是在小企业TikTok兴起之前。就像当时根本没有那种东西，你知道的，没有人为他们的业务创作内容。我甚至还记得当年我刚开始做Fate时心想，哦，我不知道我是不是能把它发到我的社交媒体上，因为我不知道我的
audience will like this because they want me to do Kmart Hall and vlog, you know, going shopping at West. Yeah, Q&A. And so I started posting a couple little YouTube videos about it. And I would never show my shed at home because that's where it was set up first. But I would go upstairs into my spare room. But this is my HQ and office. But then I would never show the garage because I was embarrassed of it. Whereas now, like in 2025 or 2026, if you were starting a business in your garage, you document the shit out of that.
但也许这就是为什么现在这么难的原因，因为感觉所有事情都必须公开。所以所有的东西都必须被人看到。因此，如果它看起来不够好、不够完美，如果它失败了，就会觉得它是如此显眼。但当年，因为没有别人这么做，所以我想：“哦，我才不展示这个呢。人们不会严肃对待我的。”但如果我能重来一次，或者如果我现在才开始，而且依然是从我的客房和棚屋里的那些塑料箱开始做起，我百分之百会把这些记录下来，因为人们就是喜欢看幕后的故事。
But maybe that's like why it's so hard these days because it's like you have to get over this. It just feels like everything has to be public. So all the things have to be perceived. So if it's not looking great, not looking perfect, if it fails, it's like it's just so visible. But back then, because no one else was doing that, I was like, oh, I'm not going to show this. People aren't going to take me seriously. But if I could have my time over, or if I was starting now and I was still starting in my spare bedroom and all the plastic tubs in my shed, I would 100% document that because people love to see that
确实如此。而且再次长话短说，Fate 在头几年不断发展壮大，我们搬了出去，在纽卡斯尔租下了第一个小仓库，雇用了第二名员工、第三名员工，然后我们有了一个小团队。2019年，我们开出了第一家实体店，这也是另一个完全不同的故事，但我们开第一家店的唯一原因，是因为我们必须再次搬迁，因为我们在不断壮大，而我们租下的那栋楼楼下有一个小型展厅。哦，太酷了，你们就想：“那就干吧！”所以那是2019年，就在新冠疫情爆发前夕。再次声明，我根本不懂怎么经营一家实体店，但我会再次去谷歌搜索。
behind the scenes. They do. And again, long story short, fate just grew over those first few years and we moved out, got our first little warehouse in Newcastle hired employee number two employee number three then we had a little team in 2019 we opened our first store and that's a whole other story as well but the only reason that we opened our first store was because we had to move again because we were growing and the building that we got had a little showroom downstairs oh cool you're like let's do it yeah so that was 2019 just before COVID again I had no idea how to run a store but I would just get on Google again
这还是在 ChatGPT 问世之前，所以我当时就在 Google 上搜索这些东西。我只记得自己当时在搜诸如：澳大利亚有什么好的收银系统（POS system），如何定制购物袋之类的。我把所有东西都在 Google 上搜了一遍。再次强调，雇用了我认识的人、家人、朋友之类的。而且刚开业时，大多数时间都是我自己呆在店里。当我开那家店的时候，我从来没想过还要开第二家。只是在 Fate 运营的这八年里，它自然而然地像滚雪球一样发展，才有了我们今天的成就。这一切都源于我当时说：“行吧，我要尝试一下。”然后就抱着“走一步算一步”的心态。
this is before chat GPT or anything so I was just Googling this stuff. And I just remember Googling like, what's a good point of sales system like to have in Australia, you know, how to get shopping bags made? Like I'm just Googling everything. Again, hide like people I knew, family, friends or whatever. And like I just worked in the shop myself most of the time when we first opened. And when I opened that store, I had no intentions of ever opening another one. It's just been like this natural snowball effect over the eight years of fate that it's gotten us to where we are today. But it all started from me, just going, yeah, I'm going to give this thing a go. And just like the one foot in front of the next kind of
确实如此。当你做的事情明显吓得你半死时，比如我记得当时我想，好吧，我们已经超过了家里那个双车库的容量了。我觉得我需要去租一个商业店铺。要花好多钱。是的，当时确实如此。我到处看，我们最后租下的那个面积大约100平方米，非常小。我想一年的租金大概是3.5万美元。我当时就记得自己在想，好吧，我有一个员工。我得付她临时工工资。然后我每年还得付3.5万美元的租金。如果我们赚不到钱怎么办，或者如果人们不买我们的产品了怎么办，你知道的，但你还是去冒了这个险，尽管它吓得你半死，接着你搬了进去，然后心想：“哦天哪，这真的行得通。”然后你再迈向下一步。
mentality. Exactly. And the more that you do things that obviously scare the crap out of you, like I remember when I thought, okay, we're outgrowing my little double garage at home. I think I need to get a commercial lease. So much of money. Yeah, it was, I was looking around and the one that we got, it was like 100 square meters, like quite small. And I think the rent was like $35,000 a year. And I just remember thinking, well, I've got my one employee. I'm having to pay her casual. And then I'm going to have to pay $35,000 a year. What if we don't make money or what if people just stop buying from us, you know, but you take that risk, even though it scares the crap out of you, then you move in, you go, oh my God, like this is working. Then you move on to the next step.
直到你真正做出了那些决定并去冒了险，你才会很快意识到，只要你迈出那一步，美好的事情就会发生。哦，是的。我们得在这里休息一下。如果我现在不休息，我的问题就要泛滥成灾了。所以我们在这里休息一下。然后我想聊聊那种“当时间对了你就会知道”的感觉。你犯过哪些错误？
And it's not until you actually make those decisions and take those risks that you'll soon realize great things can happen if you just take that step. Oh, yeah. We need to take a break here. I'm going to get over my head with questions if I don't take a break now. So we're going to take a break here. And then I want to talk about this feeling of like, you know when the time is right. What were some of the mistakes you made?
Google 没有教过你的事情有哪些？所以请继续收听，我们马上回来。《百分之二》。这是指在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《百分之二》中。我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及构建抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
What are some of the things Google didn't teach you? So stick around. We'll be right back. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
我们真的以为种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。名字是 T-W-O-Percent，请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）莉尔·金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人的时候。我知道你在想什么。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）合作的节目，滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克（crack）毒品。澄清一下，1984年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为国会。快克。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of Congress. crack.
我倒是挺乐意在白天聊聊快克的，但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们第二次讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple 播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听 Look Back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我在谈论。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
而我们却还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·布恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上当一个好人很重要？你当一个好人是因为你害怕吗？
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
因为这是两种完全不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地、纯粹地去当一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中惊人的前后矛盾。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。
Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，那个同性恋。迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。玩蠢游戏，就会得到蠢下场。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《女朋友们》的全新一季中，天呐，这竟然是同一个男人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Speaking of Google and speaking of like a very DIY, intuitive gut kind of approach, what's something that you could never have Googled, that you learned in like the first two years of building fate? Everything.
他罪有应得。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女朋友们》。说到谷歌，说到那种非常 DIY、直观的直觉式方法，有什么东西是你永远无法通过谷歌搜索到，而你在创立 Fate 的前两年左右学到的呢？一切。
Everything. Business is just making mistakes constantly and learning better for next time. You're never going to be perfect at any of it. Like you just always, it's like a self-improvement journey, owning a business. But some things in particular that Google couldn't have prepared me for. One of the main things would be probably the emotional journey of going on a business, going on a business, starting a business, you know what I mean? And also how much starting a business isn't about you at all.
一切。商业就是不断犯错，并为下一次做得更好吸取教训。你永远不可能在任何事情上都做到完美。就像经营企业一样，你总是处在一个自我提升的旅程中。但有些事情是谷歌无法让我做好准备的。其中最主要的一点，可能就是经营企业、开展业务、创业的情感之旅，你知道我的意思吗？还有就是，创业其实根本不是为了你自己。
Because when we start a business, it is kind of selfish, right? Because you're like, I want to start this for me, because I have worked in over 20 jobs and I hated them all and I want to start this for me. but if you actually want to start a business and you want to turn it into something, it's eventually going to involve other people. And when you own a business and you have staff, it's no longer about you anymore. And looking at my business now, people would probably see like our fate social media and my social media. And it probably just looks like the Britney show because I'm like the face of the brand and whatever. But in my day-to-day life, when I'm at work from Monday to Friday in the office,
因为当我们创业时，这其实有点自私，对吧？因为你会想，我想为自己开创这个事业，因为我做过 20 多份工作，我讨厌所有这些工作，我想为自己开创这个事业。但如果你真的想开创一份事业，并想把它做成点什么，它最终必然会涉及到其他人。当你拥有自己的公司并拥有员工时，这一切就再也不是关于你自己的了。看看我现在的业务，人们可能会看到我们的 Fate 社交媒体和我的社交媒体。这可能看起来就像是布兰妮秀，因为我是品牌的门面之类的人。但在我的日常生活中，当我周一到周五在办公室工作时，
it is not about me at all. It's about everyone else. And I think that's something that Google couldn't have taught me. You learn as you go from, you know, people management, dealing with people's wants, needs, emotions, their personal lives and things that they bring into work from the outside, just learning to manage people. I didn't have one day of experience as even a team leader in any of the jobs that I had.
这根本不是为了我。这是为了其他人。我认为这是谷歌教不了我的东西。你在实践中不断学习，比如人员管理、处理员工的期望、需求、情绪、他们的个人生活，以及他们从外部带到工作中的事情，学会管理人员。在我做过的所有工作中，我甚至连一天团队领导的经验都没有。
So I think it's like the people and emotional side of business that Google definitely couldn't have prepared me for. What was like the most costly mistake that you made in like the early days? Do you remember having a moment where you were like, oh, my God, we cannot make that mistake again? Yes, I definitely have an answer for this. But at the time, it wasn't an expensive mistake. But if I could do my time over again, I would have done it differently. And that would be hiring the right people at the beginning of my business.
所以我认为，这是商业中关于人际和情感的一面，谷歌绝对无法让我做好准备。你在早期犯下的代价最高昂的错误是什么？你还记得有过这样的时刻吗，当时你想，天呐，我们绝对不能再犯那种错误了？是的，我绝对有答案。但当时，这并不是一个昂贵的错误。不过如果能重来一次，我会用不同的方式处理。那就是在创业初期雇佣对的人。
Yes. When we start a business, especially when it's small and it was just at home for me at the beginning, my. And because I wasn't taking it seriously because I didn't have this big business plan. It was easy for me back then to go, I'm just going to hire all my friends, all my friends's friends and all my family friends. I do. I've done this. I feel like every business owner does. You want to help.
是的。当我们创业时，特别是当它规模还很小，一开始对我来说只是在家里做的时候。而且因为我当时没有认真对待它，因为我没有宏大的商业计划。那时候对我来说很容易的一件事就是，我打算雇佣我所有的朋友、所有朋友的朋友以及所有家人的朋友。我确实这么做了。我觉得每个企业主都会这么做。你想帮忙。
It's just a thing of like, who do I trust the most? Exactly right. And you think, oh, this is going to be fun. Yeah. You know, because you're not serious about your business. You just want it to be fine. Yeah, I'll work with my best friend and my cousin and this and that and the other. Sister, yeah, all these things.
这其实就是一种“我最信任谁”的想法。完全正确。然后你会想，哦，这会很有趣。是的。你知道的，因为你并没有认真对待你的生意。你只是希望一切都好。好吧，我会和我最好的朋友、我的表弟、这个那个一起工作。还有姐姐，是的，所有这些事情。
And at the beginning of any business, it's fine for it to be that way. And, you know, some businesses are family run or friends together and it works. But for me, personally, one of the biggest discoveries for me, probably for the first three years. I always like to say that the first three years of a business is like a trial. And then after three years, that's when it turned into a real business. Okay, yeah. But yeah, for the first three years of fate, it was pretty unsurious. It was a lot of fun.
在任何生意的初期，这样是可以的。而且，你知道，有些生意是家族经营的或者是朋友合伙的，它确实行得通。但对我个人而言，我最大的发现之一，大概是在前三年。我总是喜欢说，创业的前三年就像是一场试炼。三年之后，那才真正变成了一家真正的企业。好吧，是的。但话说回来，在 Fate 的前三年，它其实挺随意的。那段时光非常快乐。
I was best friends with everyone that I employed. We were all hanging out outside of work and drinking on the weekends and going to each other's house and all that kind of stuff. And then as the business grew, I realized I can't have this like mix of personal friendships and relationships in a business because the lines just become. Everything becomes a personal insult, every piece of feedback. And you hesitate to say things that you really should. That's because you care about them. avoiding hard conversations was another big one of mine in those early years because, yeah, we're naturally people pleases. We don't want to upset anyone. And then if we're besties with someone that's also working for us and they kind of do something wrong or they've slacked
我和我雇佣的每个人都是好朋友。我们在工作之外一起闲逛，周末喝酒，去彼此家里，诸如此类的事情。然后随着业务的发展，我意识到我不能在商业中有这种个人友谊和关系的混合，因为界限会变得模糊。每一条反馈，每一样东西都变成了人身攻击。而且你会犹豫，不敢说出你真正应该说的话。那是因为你在乎他们。逃避艰难的对话是我早年间另一个很大的问题，因为，是的，我们天生都是老好人。我们不想惹任何人不高兴。然后如果我们和某位为我们工作的人是闺蜜，而他们做错了什么或者偷懒了，
off, you don't want to go, hey, like I just noticed that you're dropping off in your work performance because then you're worried. They're going, what are you talking about? Like, you know, because you're friends. And so I would say looking back, if I could do my journey all over again, I wouldn't redo it, you know, at any point. But I guess if I was starting today, one of the biggest lessons that I've learned in my business journey, and it's great advice for any business owner out there, it doesn't matter how far you are into your journey is, it's cliche, but people will either make or break your business.
你不会想去说，嘿，我注意到你的工作表现下降了，因为那样你会担心。他们会说，你在说什么呢？因为你们是朋友。所以我想说回过头来看，如果我能重来一次我的旅程，我在任何节点上都不会去重新来过。但我想如果我是今天才开始创业，我在商业旅程中学到的最大教训之一——对于任何企业主来说这都是极好的建议，无论你已经走了多远——虽然是个老生常谈，但人确实能成就你的生意，也能毁了你的生意。
And if you're serious about your business, which I wasn't at the start, not many people are because you just don't think big picture, I would hire the right people that are serious about my business and not take the easy route of just hiring friends and family. But, you know, I have no regrets and it worked at the time. Yeah. But on reflection now and looking where we are in 2025 where I've just got a team full of A players who are so serious about fate and their careers and they want growth and progression and I'm watching them build careers right before my eyes. I'm like, oh, I should have done this from the beginning. But I don't think you can. I think you've got to go through all the motions and again, like learn from your mistakes so that you can do
如果你对你的生意是认真的——我刚开始时并不是，很多人也不是，因为你不会去想大局——我会雇佣那些对我的生意认真、合适的人，而不是走捷径去雇佣朋友和家人。但是，你知道，我并不后悔，当时那种做法确实行之通。是的。但现在反思起来，看看我们在 2025 年所处的位置，我刚刚拥有一支全明星阵容的团队，他们对 Fate 极其认真，对自己的职业生涯极其认真，他们渴望成长和进步，我眼看着他们建立自己的职业生涯。我会想，哦，我应该从一开始就这么做的。但我不认为你可以（一开始就做到）。我认为你必须经历所有的波折，再次强调，从错误中吸取教训，这样你才能在未来做得更好。
better in the future. Yeah, I like what you said. I think what you're really saying is like if you had the option or if somebody listening to has a fledgling business and has the option, take the option of hiring somebody you don't, you don't know. Exactly. Yeah. Somebody who is coming in as an employee, full stop, nothing else. Exactly right. And also hiring people that are better than you. Yeah. That's another one. again, like all business owners, and I don't want anyone to think that what I'm saying is wrong, but for the first four years of fate, I was so fine with hiring people that had no experience at all and teaching them everything that I knew because I had taught myself how to do every part of
是的，我喜欢你所说的话。我想你真正想表达的是，如果你有选择，或者如果某位听众正处于创业初期并且有这个选择，那就选择雇佣一个你不认识的人。完全正确。是的。一个作为一个单纯的员工入职的人，句号，别无其他。完全正确。还有就是雇佣比你更优秀的人。是的。这是另一件。再次强调，像所有企业主一样——我不想让任何人觉得我说得不对——但在 Fate 的前四年里，我很乐意雇佣那些完全没有经验的人，并把我知道的一切都教给他们，因为我自己学会了如何做生意的每一个环节，
the business from packing orders to doing our email campaigns in Canva and building Shopify and doing products and all this kind of stuff. So for those first four years, I would always just hire someone that was nice and friendly and that I got along with. But another lesson for me, and especially like in the most recent years, is it sure, it might cost more to hire someone who comes with a wealth of experience. And as a business owner, you know, that can be scary to have someone who's wanting a higher pay based on their experience. But it's priceless to have someone come in who knows their shit and knows what they can do for the business. Rather than bringing someone in and sure, you might not have to pay them as much because they've got no experience,
从打包订单到在 Canva 上做我们的电子邮件营销活动，再到构建 Shopify、做产品以及所有诸如此类的事情。所以在前四年里，我总是只雇佣那些人很好、很友好、和我合得来的人。但对我的另一个教训是，特别是在最近几年，当然，雇佣一个经验丰富的人可能会花费更多。作为一个企业主，你知道，让一个根据经验要求更高薪酬的人加入可能会让人害怕。但能有一个真正懂行、知道能为公司做些什么的人加入，是无价的。而不是带进来一个人，当然，你可能不用付给他们那么多钱，因为他们没有经验，
but then how much time are you spending, teaching that person everything and double checking everything. So that's probably another one of mine is hiring the right people and not being afraid to hire people who are better than you at certain things. So they can come in and own their space rather than you being a helicopter boss trying to make sure, you know, the email looks right before it goes out and the Instagram stories are all good, just all those little things. They can just do it. Yeah. Yeah. What does a typical day in your life look like nowadays? And you kind of gave us an insight, but you used to, you know, the history of Britain, it's like you used to be really prominent on social media and you were mainly influencing and now you're running this business. And like, what does that mean? You know when people always like, oh, you run a business, what do you do on a day to day?
但随后你要花多少时间去教那个人所有事情并双重检查每一件事？所以这可能也是我的经验之一，即雇佣对的人，并且不要害怕雇佣在某些方面比你更优秀的人。这样他们就可以进来独当一面，而不是让你成为一个直升机老板，试图确保——你知道——电子邮件在发送前看起来没问题，Instagram 快拍都很好，只是所有这些小事。他们自己就能搞定。是的。是的。你如今的日常生活是怎样的？你其实已经给我们提供了一些见解，但你以前，你知道，布兰妮的历史，就像你以前在社交媒体上非常活跃，你主要是在做网红，而现在你在经营这家生意。这意味着什么？你知道当人们总是说，哦，你经营一家生意，你每天都做些什么？
Yeah. Clit, but no two days are the same. I gave up influencing. I want to say two or three years ago now. Did you make an announcement or were you just like... It was very gradual over the years. I went from doing a sponsored post like every second day on Instagram and I really narrowed it down. And by the end, I think I was only working with two brands that I had ongoing partnerships with. There were Esme skincare. Do you know Esme?
是的。老生常谈，但没有哪两天是完全一样的。我放弃做网红了。我想大概是两三年前吧。你当时发布了公告，还是说你只是……这些年来非常循序渐进。我从在 Instagram 上每隔一天发布一篇赞助帖子，慢慢缩减。到最后，我想我只和两个保持长期合作关系的品牌合作。那是 Esme 护肤品。你知道 Esme 吗？
Esme? I don't know the proper way to say it. ESMI. Oh yeah, yeah. You would probably know it if you saw it. Oh yeah. I know. When you said I was like, yeah.
Esme？我不知道正确的发音方式。ESMI。哦，对，对。如果你看到它，你可能会认出来。哦，对。我知道。你一说我就想起来了。
Classic Australian brand. Yes. and Canadian club because I'd work with them a heap of times. That's not what I expected you to say. Yeah. So at the end, they were the two brands that I was left working with. And I'd given up like all the hairstyling tool brands. Like I worked with GHD for a really long time.
典型的澳大利亚品牌。是的。还有加拿大俱乐部（Canadian Club），因为我和他们合作过很多次。这不是我意料之中你会说的答案。是的。所以到最后，剩下的就是与这两个品牌的合作。而且我考虑了一两年要不要也把这些放弃，因为我和他们有长期的合作关系。我去找我的会计师说，我想把这一切都彻底放弃，因为我当时就像是作为一家公司的布兰妮·李·桑德斯（Brittany Lee Saunders），然后我还有 Fate。作为网红的好处是，在前四年里，我根本不需要从 Fate 领任何薪水。那是我的问题之一。
All sorts of ones. And I ended up only having the two partnerships. And I sat on the idea for maybe a year or two to also give those up because I had like ongoing partnerships with them. And I went to my accountant and I said, I think I just want to give up this all together because I was like Brittany Lee Saunders as a company and then I had fate. And the great thing about being an influencer was I didn't have to pay myself anything from fate for the first like four years of fate. That was one of my questions.
是的，我什么都没拿。我运营 Fate，同时把做网红当成副业，做网红赚的是我的个人钱。然后业务产生的所有钱都用来支付员工薪水，并重新投入到业务中。所以，是的，大概是两三年前，也许是三年前吧。三年前，我决定放弃品牌合作。那个时候我已经放弃 YouTube 了。只是因为我忙着经营公司，我必须优先把时间花在发展业务上，而不是制作 YouTube 视频。然后，是的，我咬牙决定不再做任何品牌合作了。那是，是的，现在是三年前了。我想在
Yeah, I didn't pay myself for anything. I worked on fate and had my influencing on the side and the influencing was my personal money. And then all the money that the business generated paid my staff and went back into the business. And so, yeah, it would have been two to three, maybe three. three years ago now, I decided I'm going to give up the brand deals. I'd already given up YouTube by that point. Just because I was getting too busy running the business and I just had to prioritize not spending my time making YouTube videos to grow the business. And then, yeah, I bit the bullet and said I'm not doing any more brand deals. And that was, yeah, three years ago now. I think over
过去的三年里，我们大概接过两个那种找上门来、觉得好到无法拒绝的合作。也就是你真正在乎的事情。是的。就像大概两年前，肯德基说，你们能在七月过圣诞节时做点什么吗？他们有一些滑稽的丑毛衣。我说，行，我们会做那个，因为那真的很有趣。是的。但在过去三年左右的时间里，我只接了几个这样的合作。
those three years, we've done like two that have like come our way that were like too good to pass up kind of thing. And things you cared about. Yeah. And like maybe two years ago, KFC said, can you please do something for Christmas in July? And they had these funny, ugly sweaters. I was like, yeah, we'll do that one because that's really fun. Yeah. But I've just done a couple over the last three-ish years.
不过，是的，我完全放弃了，这让我首先可以开始从 Fate 作为一名真正的员工领薪水，并且每周都能拿到工资单和所有东西。天呐。是的，多有趣啊。是的，这真的让人很兴奋。而且这让我能够完全专注于 Fate，而不必担心“哦，我得为某某品牌完成这个帖子”。我今天的一天是这样的，我是一个亲力亲为的创始人和首席执行官。
But yeah, I fully gave it up, which just then allowed me, number one, to start paying myself from Fade as an actual employee and getting a pay slip and everything every week. Oh, my God. Yeah, how fun. Yeah, which was really exciting. And then it's just allowed me to fully focus on fate rather than worrying about, oh, I've got to get this post done for so-and-so brand. What my day looks like today, I'm a very hands-on founder and CEO.
我与我们的营销团队密切合作，负责 Fate 的所有营销事宜，无论是我们正在做的盛大活动，还是我们的任何客户品牌旅行——这非常棒，可以从网红转型中延续下来。解释一下这些是什么。客户品牌旅行对你们来说相当具有标志性。是的，我们现在已经办了两次了。我们去年在七岁生日时启动了这个活动，为了庆祝我们的七岁生日。每年我们的生日临近时，团队就会对我说，糟了，两周后就是我们的生日了。我们好像什么都没组织。去年，我想我们在生日前两个月才
I work heavily with our marketing team for all things marketing at fate, whether that's big campaigns that we're doing, any of our customer brand trips that we do, which has been awesome to do, like, off the back of influencing. Explain what these are. The customer brand trips are pretty. iconic for you guys. Yeah, so we've done two now. We started it on our seventh birthday last year to celebrate our seventh birthday. Every year our birthday comes around and the team will go to me, shit, it's our birthday in two weeks. Like we haven't organized anything. And last year, I think we thought
开始考虑生日的事，因为你不会去想你公司的生日。你有太多事情要忙了。而且它在九月。所以这就像是即将迎来忙碌期。我就想，好吧，为什么我们不带七个客户去进行一次品牌旅行呢？有点像我过去常去的那种所有的品牌旅行。但与其带网红，不如带客户，像对待网红那样对待他们。然后“幸运七人组”的创意就是这样诞生的。我们做了一个盛大的抽奖活动，七个随机抽中的客户赢得了与我们一起旅行的机会。这太轰动了，我们从中得到了这么多的内容，他们度过了最棒的时光，而且他们都结下了深厚的友谊。我们和他们在一起呆了三天。你们去了哪里？我们把他们带到了纽卡斯尔（Newcastle）。我们当时想，就在家乡开始吧。
about our birthday like two months before because you don't think about your business as birthday. You got too much going on. And it's in September. So it's like coming up to the busy period. And I was like, well, why don't we take seven customers on a brand trip, kind of like how I used to go on all the brand trips back in the day. But instead of taking influences, let's take customers and like treat them like influencers. And so then that's where the idea of the lucky seven came to be. And we did a big old giveaway and seven random customers won a trip with us. And it was like such a hit and we got so much content out of it and they had the best time and they all made such great friends. We were with them for three days. Where did you go? We brought them to Newcastle. We were like, let's start it at home.
是的。纽卡斯尔也很有氛围。是的。而且我们现在有了五星级酒店。所以我们把他们安排在……纽卡斯尔有五星级酒店吗？是的，我们有两个，以前从来没有过。但纽卡斯尔现在发展真的很快。不过，是的，他们都有自己的酒店房间，我们在床上摆满了来自不同品牌的各种好东西。这完全是一次网红级别的旅行。这次活动非常成功，以至于我们在今年九月又办了一次。为了我们的八岁生日，我们把它叫做 Fate 8。去年是“幸运七人组”。同样，只是一次抽奖，八个客户。这次我们把他们带到了史蒂芬港（Port Stevens）。我不知道
Yeah. Newcastle is also a vibe. Yeah. And we've got like, five-star hotels now. So we put them in... Do you have a five-star hotel in Newcastle? Yeah, we got two, which we never used to have. But Newie's really up and coming. But yeah, they all got their own hotel room and we decked out the bed with all the goodies from all the different brands. It was like a full influencer trip. And so that was such a success that we've done it again just this year in September. And we called it the Fate 8 for our 8th birthday. And last year was a lucky seven. And again, just a giveaway, eight customers. We took them to Port Stevens this time. I don't know
你们知不知道那个地方。我们租了一栋很大很漂亮的房子。更像是静修的氛围。所以这真的很酷，能够做到这一点。但，是的，我与营销团队紧密合作。我监督 Fate 的领导团队。有一项工作可能会让人感到惊讶，我至今仍在 Fate 里做，而且我不知道自己是否能放弃，那就是我负责我们所有的库存采购和订购。哦，真的吗？
if you know where that is. We got this big, beautiful house. us and it was more of like a retreat vibe. So that's been really cool to be able to do. But yeah, I work heavily with our marketing team. I oversee our leadership team at Fait. One job that would surprise people that I still do in FATE and I don't know if I could ever give it up is I do all of our stock buying and ordering. Oh, really?
是的。哦，酷。所以进入我们公司的每一件衣服都是我的责任去订购，而且我们所有的店面库存和所有门店的采购都是我负责。不会吧。这绝对是最难的工作之一。这是一项重大的工作，但我想因为我从第一天起就在做，所以我闭着眼睛都能做。
Yeah. Oh, cool. So every piece of clothing that comes into our business is my responsibility to order and all of our store stock and buying for all the stores is me. No way. That's like one of the hardest jobs. It's a big job, but I think because I've been doing it since day one, I could do it with my eyes closed.
而且因为我们的发展非常循序渐进，这对我来说很容易学习。比如订购更多的库存。是的，这家店需要这个，那家店需要那个。是的。我和我们的运营经理一起处理这个，但这是我的主要任务之一。我负责我们的广告账户。酷。是的。
And because we've grown so gradually, it's been easy for me to learn. Like ordering more stocks. Yeah, and this store needs this and that store needs that. Yeah. And I work with our operations manager on that, but that's like one of my main tasks. I run out ad accounts. Cool. Yeah.
所以我喜欢 Meta 和 Facebook 广告。作为老板和创始人，我仍然亲力亲为很多。但我确实正处于业务旅程中的这样一个节点：我感觉我需要退后一步，更多地扮演一个创始人的角色，而不是陷入诸如“哪个 UGC 创作者还没有把他们的内容发过来”这种琐事中，你知道我的意思吗？
So I love meta and Facebook ads. I do a lot still. as the owner and founder. But I'm definitely getting to the point in my business journey where I am feeling like I need to kind of step away and start being more of a founder rather than getting caught up in what UGC creator hasn't sent their content in. You know what I mean?
是的，我甚至都不……但我确实——这也是所有创始人都会遇到的情况，如果他们的业务增长到一定规模，就会发现自己陷入了日常琐事中。但我绝对在随着业务的发展而学习：我需要专注于那些大局方面的事情，而不是那个客户在邮件里说了什么，你知道吗？
Yeah, I do not even. But I am, again, it's something that all founders, if their business grows to a certain size, they will find themselves in that situation where you do get pulled into the day to day. But I'm definitely learning as we're growing. I need to focus on those big picture things rather than what did that customer say in that email, you know?
最好无视。是的。至少你。删除。至少。好吧，拜拜。删除。直接把它扔进垃圾桶，说它进了垃圾箱。
Best to ignore. Yeah. At least you. Delete. At least. Well, bye. Delete. Just put it in the bin and say it went to spam.
是的。不过，是的，没有哪两天是完全一样的。而且我仍然深度参与整个业务，从零售到仓库以及介于两者之间的所有事情。但归根结底我爱这份工作。所以我自从创立 Fate 以来，真的没有一天是在工作。我喜欢这样。我们再休息一下。
Yeah. But yeah, no two days the same. And I'm still very much involved with the whole business from retail to warehouse and everything in between. But I love it at the end of the day. So I literally haven't worked a day since I started fate. I like that. We're going to take one more break. and then I have three more questions for you.
然后我还有三个问题要问你。所以请继续关注我们。2%。这就是当自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的
So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex students.
科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的。请收听《2%》。即 T-W-O-Percent，在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
science that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是 Sam J。我是 Alex English。每一集里，我们都会深入探讨，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）做客，大谈 80 年代的快克（crack）。
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
需要明确的是，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为乌鸦。快克。我随时准备在白天谈论快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条主线了。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crows. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算做够了。
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你们觉得作为一个在世的好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这是两个不同层面的信任。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
我希望你们能真正做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的 iHeart Radio App，搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达多年的法庭之战以证明真相。你对某人的这份特定测试篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我想让人们看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Marantini）。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
在正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在亚利桑那州伸张正义。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。玩蠢游戏，就会得到蠢下场。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。
This isn't over until Justice. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《女朋友们》的全新一季中，天呐，这竟然是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。
I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我说，噢，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他罪有应得。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女朋友们》。所以我们在谈论你可能不回复电子邮件的事。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So we're talking about you, not replying to emails, maybe.
那是我的工作之一——我放弃了回复客户服务电子邮件，这感觉真好。因为我觉得当你经营自己的生意时，事情会变得非常个人化。比方说，有人发邮件对某些事情感到不满。如果你读到那个，就会觉得，哦，操。每当我收到差评时。我知道，这很伤人。确实如此。真的很糟糕。
That's one job I have given up is replying to our customer service emails, which has been nice. Because I feel like it gets to a point where it feels so much more personal when it's your business. Like let's say someone is emailing and they're upset with something. And then if you're reading that, it's like, oh, fuck. Anytime I get a bad review. I know, it hurts. It really does. It really stinks.
不过没关系，我们有专门的人来回复那些，这很好。我没有。我只是不回复它们。展望未来，你下一步有什么计划？你觉得你还会创办另一家公司吗？会。天呐，太酷了。我很乐意。
No, we've got people that reply to those, which is great. I don't. I just don't reply to them. Looking towards the future, what are you planning next? Do you think that you will launch another business? Yeah. Oh my God, cool. I would love to.
你觉得那会是什么？如果你有的话，你最近有没有过这样一种想法：我不确定你是不是像我一样。我的手机里有一份包含两千万个商业点子的清单。有时我只是把它们给别人，随机跟人提起，然后说你应该做那个。是的，我不知道该怎么做，但你应该去做。你也有类似的东西吗？有太多我想做的事情了。这只是一个什么时候去实行的问题。
What do you think it would be? And if you have, have you had an idea recently where you're like, I don't know if you're like me. I have like a list of my phone of like 20 million business ideas. Sometimes I just give them, I just randomly mention them to people and like you should make that. Yeah, I don't know how to do that, but you should do it. Do you have something like that? There's so many things that I would love to do. It's just a matter of getting around to doing it.
而且我也把自己给套牢了，因为 Fate 是一家相当大的公司。哦，规模很大。所以，是的，我有点把自己和 Fate 绑在一起了。你会觉得，哦，你正在承受成功的烦恼。我喜欢这样。我想做的事情太多了。我有我的商业播客叫《Big Business》，我非常喜欢做这个。我发现自己非常倾向于在他们的商业旅程中帮助别人，
And also I've kind of stitched myself up because Faye's quite a big company. Oh, it's huge. So, yeah, I kind of have got myself tied into Faye. You're like, oh, you're suffering from success. I love it. There's so much that I want to do. I have my business podcast called Big Business, which I absolutely love doing. I feel very drawn to helping others on their business journey,
仅仅基于我所学到的一切。所以我喜欢做我的单集节目。我在那个播客里每周做两集，我就是喜欢这个。我喜欢围绕商业制作内容，而且我注意到人们喜欢我在 TikTok、Reel 等平台上谈论商业。我有一部分内心想成为一名商业教练或导师，也许在另一段人生中我会这么做，或者在这段人生的某个时候我会抽出时间去做。你还有很长的路要走。是的，完全正确。而且我也觉得，我最近做了很多主题演讲。
just based off everything that I've learned. So I love doing my episodes. I do two episodes a week on that podcast, and I just love that. I love making content around business, and I've noticed that people love when I talk about business in like my TikToks and reels and stuff like that. Part of me wants to become like a business coach or a mentor, like maybe in another life, I'll do it or I'll get around to it in this life. You've got a lot more life to live. Yeah, exactly right. And I think as well, like I've been doing a lot of keynote speeches lately.
我最近刚做了一场 TEDx 演讲，这太棒了。感觉怎么样？真的很酷。就在几个周末前。所以我也喜欢做主题演讲并在人群面前发言，无论是关于商业还是普遍具有激励意义的事情，我想是的。所以我喜欢这样。总有一天我也想办一个属于我自己的巡回演出加工作坊之类的活动。但我愿意尝试任何和所有的事情。
I just recently did a TEDx talk, which was awesome. What was that like? Really cool. That was just a couple of weekends ago. So I love doing keynotes and talking in front of crowds, whether it's about business or just being inspirational in general, I guess. So I love that. I'd love to do like a tour slash workshop thing of my own one day. but I'd love to do anything and everything.
我最近有个点子，还为此拍了个小视频。这些年来很多人对我说，嗯，你太容易了，你一直很幸运，因为你在网上拥有粉丝。所以，理所当然地，你能够做到你所做的事。而我想说，刚开始时也许是这样，没错，但要把一项业务真正发展并扩大到 Fate 现在的规模，需要完全不同的东西。任何网红都可以推出一款产品，但是，不是所有人都能
I had this one idea recently that I made a little video about. A lot of people have said to me over the years that, well, you've had it easy and you've been, you've been lucky because you had an audience online. So, like, of course, you've been able to do what you've done. And I'm like, kind of at the start, yeah, sure, but it takes something completely different to actually grow and scale a business into the size that fate is. Any influencer can launch a product, but, like, not everyone can. can keep it going and then grow it.
让它持续下去并让它不断增长。抱歉这么说，一款产品对比——你们现在有多少产品？非常多。你们至少有 150 种款式，可能更多。是的。而且我们有，你知道，五家门店，70 名员工。所以它已经发展成了一个超越我个人的东西，不仅仅是因为我是一个网红而且很幸运。但在听到人们对我说这些评论之后——哦，对你来说很容易，因为你以前是个网红——
And sorry to say this, a product versus how many products do you have right now? So many. You would have at least 150 items for saying, probably more. Yeah. And we've got, you know, five stores, 70 staff. So like it's grown into something bigger than me just being an influencer and being lucky. But off the back of people saying those comments to me, like, oh, it's easy for you because you were an influencer back in the day.
我几乎想创办一家“无脸”公司。有趣。然后去经营它。这太疯狂了——比如搞一个匿名的生意？是的。而且永远不告诉任何人。是的，永远不告诉任何人，试着把它做到超级火爆，或者中等规模，然后
I would almost love to start a faceless business. Interesting. And do that. I think about this is crazy. Like do like an anonymous business? Yes. And never tell anyone. Yeah, never tell anyone and try to make it super popular or even medium size and then
亮明身份说，这是我做的。而且你们谁都不知道，只是为了证明在作为品牌门面的另一面，我同样具备成功的能力。我要在这里透露我的另一个点子。我很想打造一个 Fate 的竞争对手。这太疯狂了，你竟然如此身处行业中心，以至于你说，我现在想成为我自己的竞争对手。是的，再创办另一个服装品牌。
come out and be like, this was me. And none of you knew just to show that I have what it takes on the other side of being the face of a brand. and I'm going to give away my other idea here. I'd love to make Fates competitor. That's crazy that you are so like in the game that you're like, I want to be my own competition now. Yeah, and start like another clothing brand.
包含所有尺码以及各种东西。是的，把一切都做好，而且要不同于 Fate。你知道，我显然不会使用我自己或我的脸，但相反我们需要——这是一笔投资——你将与模特、创作者、网红、UGC、付费广告和付费媒体合作。我很乐意看到——这需要几年的时间。是的。但我很乐意打造一个 Fate 的竞争对手，然后每个人都对这个拥有所有尺码及一切的新服装品牌着迷。是的，而且你可以更大胆地进行实验。是的。然后到头来其实只有我一个人。然后我会说，惊喜，其实是我。接着我把它们合并在一起。
With extended sizes and everything. Yeah, do it all and like different to FATE. And you know, I obviously wouldn't use myself or my face, but instead we'd have to, it's an investment. you'd be working with models, creators, influencers, UGC, paid ads and paid media. And I'd love to look like, it would take years. Yeah. But I'd love to build like Fate's competitor and everyone becomes obsessed with this other
Kate and Fait。这可以起成你的名字。所以这就是我的一个点子。但我对一切持开放态度，我绝对相信我这辈子还会创办其他公司。我仍然觉得我对 Fate 来说才刚刚开始。所以 Fate 还有很多令人兴奋的事情值得探索。我从来没有想过我们能走到今天这一步。说实话，我刚开始的时候，目光根本无法越过那个车库。我觉得这正是你故事中最酷的部分。对于那些说“哦，你知道的，你有一个平台”的人来说。你也是在 16 岁时辍学的。
new clothing brand that's got all these sizes and everything. Yeah, and you can be more experimental. Yeah. And then it's just me at the end of the day. And then I'm like, surprise, it was me. And then I merge them together. Kate and Fait. It could be your name.
是的。你没有——你在 10 年级辍学时能拿到高中毕业证书吗？没有。是的。哦，不，我想我拿到了 10 年级结业证书。10 年级结业证书。是的，我拿到了那个，这意味着什么。是的，但这就像对某人说“哦，你，你有一个大学学位。这就是你创业的方式”。
So that's an idea of mine. But I'm open to. anything and I definitely think I will start other businesses in my lifetime. I still feel like I'm just getting started with fate. So there's a lot of exciting things to explore with fate. I never thought that we would get to where we are today. Like I kid you not, I couldn't see past that garage when I first started. Which I think that's like the coolest part of your story. And for people being like, oh, you know, well, you had a platform. You also dropped out of school at 16 years old. Yeah. You didn't have a, do you get a high school diploma when you drop out in year 10?
或者每个人都有某种优势，或者所有人——比如你的父母。他们开了一家咖啡馆。所以你一开始就——每个人都有某种优势，某种好运。是的。我坚信这一点。YouTube 订阅者，当然，那对我是个优势。
No. Yeah. Oh no, I think I got my Year 10 certificate. Year 10 certificate. Yeah, I got that, which means nothing. Yeah, but that's like being like turning to someone and being like, well, you, you had a university degrees. Like, that's how you start your business.
但同时，我经营那个 YouTube 频道很多年。是的。我经营那个社区很多年。而且，你知道，我当时推出 Fate 可能会好一年，然后就 flop（搞砸）了。但这八年来的努力工作、决心和坚持，你知道的，我每周工作七天。但我喜欢它。所以我从来不觉得自己在工作。正是这种精神让我走到了今天。当然，订阅者在开始时提供了帮助，因为从第一天起就有人下单。但规模化经营完全是
Or everyone has a one up or like all your parents. They had a cafe. So you're on your, like everybody has some kind of advantage. Yes. Everybody has good luck, some kind of good luck. Yeah. I truly believe it. The YouTube subscribers, sure, that was an advantage for me.
另一回事。是的。我完全可以想象。是的。我还有一个最后的问题要问你。是的。这也是我们问每一位来到播客的嘉宾的问题。顺便说一句，我可以坐在这里聊几个小时。我知道。老实说，你知道，我们已经在这里待了。你得请我回来录第二部分。我其实很想。有那么多问题我想问，比如“解雇第一个人的感觉是什么样的？”诸如此类。
But also, I built that YouTube channel for years. Yeah. I built that community for. for years. And, you know, I could have launched fate and it could have been good for a year and that it could have flopped. But it's been like the hard work and determination over those eight years and the persistence, you know, I work seven days a week. But I love it. So I never feel like I'm working. But it's that that's gotten to me, like to where I am. Sure, the subscribers helped at the start because I had people placing orders from day one. But scaling is a whole other
林林总总。有太多问题了。发出第一封警告信。是的。对任何人来说都不好玩。当别人抄袭你时会发生什么，诸如此类的事情。但我有一个最后的问题，也就是本播客的核心问题。对于正处于 20 多岁的人，或者或许是你年轻时的自己，你有一条什么建议是和我们今天聊的内容完全无关的，完全独立的？和任何事情都无关。我知道，不能谈论生意。不能谈论你可以谈的。但谁知道呢。比如尝试，如果它是关于爱情，如果它是关于友情，如果它是关于……我有一句我非常喜欢的名言，但我不知道。你可以告诉我这是否和我们一直在谈论的话题有关。
all of a ballgame. Yeah. I can only imagine. Yeah. I have one final question for you. Yes. And this is the question that we ask everybody who comes on the podcast. I could sit here for hours, by the way. I know. I honestly, you know, we've been here. You have to get me back for part two. I kind of want to. There's so many questions that I want to ask that I'm like, what was it like to fire your first person? Like, what was it?
完全是两码事。是的。我完全可以想象。是的。我有一个最后的问题要问你。是的。这就是我们问每一个来参加播客的嘉宾的问题。顺便说一句，我可以坐在这里几个小时。我知道。老实说，你知道，我们已经在这了。你得让我回来录第二期。我有点想。有那么多问题我想问，比如，解雇你的第一个员工是什么感觉？比如，那是什么样的？
Blah, blah, blah. Like so many questions. Handing out first warning letter. Yeah. Never fun. Never fun for anyone. What happens when people copy you, like all that stuff? But I have one final question, which is the question of the podcast. What is one piece of advice you have for people in their 20s or perhaps you're
巴拉巴拉。有这么多问题。发出第一封警告信。是的。一点也不好玩。对任何人来说都不好玩。当别人抄袭你时会发生什么，诸如此类的事情。但我有一个最后的问题，也就是本期播客的固定问题。对于二十多岁的人，或者也许是你
younger self that has nothing to do with what we talked about today, completely separate. Has nothing to do with anything. I know, you can't talk about business. Can't talk about what you can. But never know. Like trying, if it's about love, if it's about friendship, if it's about. I've got a saying that I absolutely love, but I don't know. You can tell me if this ties into what we've been talking about.
年轻时的自己，你有什么建议是与我们今天讨论的内容无关的，完全独立的。跟任何东西都没有关系。我知道，你不能谈论商业。不能谈论你可以谈论的。但世事难料。比如尝试，无论是关于爱情，还是关于友谊，还是关于。我有一句我非常喜欢的名言，但我不知道。你可以告诉我这是否与我们刚才谈论的有关。
It kind of does, but it can apply to any aspect and element of your life. And the saying is do it scared. Can I say that as my answer? I like it. Yeah, do it scared. Do it scared. I think the number one thing that holds people back from doing anything in life, and this doesn't mean just starting a business.
确实是这样，但它适用于你生活的方方面面和每个元素。这句名言就是：带着恐惧去做。我能把这当成我的回答吗？我喜欢。是的，带着恐惧去做。带着恐惧去做。我认为阻碍人们在生活中做任何事情的第一大头号因素，这不仅仅指创业。
It could be saying hello to the guy that you keep seeing at the coffee shop, but you're too scared. Or it could be asking your boss for a raise or a promotion. It could be speaking up in a team meeting where you'd normally stay quiet because you're worried that people might judge you. It could be anything. It could be telling a friend of yours that they've been upsetting you lately by things they've been saying, but you don't say anything because you're too scared.
它可能是对你在咖啡馆经常碰到却又太害怕而不敢打招呼的那个男生说声嗨。或者可能是向老板要求加薪或升职。可能是在团队会议上大声说出你的想法，而你平时可能会保持沉默，因为担心别人会评判你。这可以是任何事。可能是告诉你的一个朋友，他们最近说的话让你感到难过，但你什么都没说，因为你太害怕了。
I just love the saying, do it scared. Because it's very easy for us to say, oh, no, I won't do that. Like, I'm too scared. We use that as an excuse to not do whatever the thing is. But I think it's a good mindfulness thought to think, I can still do the thing even with the scared feeling. Being scared shouldn't be someone's reason to not do something. You can just do it and still feel scared at the same time. Yeah.
我就是喜欢这句名言，带着恐惧去做。因为我们很容易说，哦，不，我不会做那个。比如，我太害怕了。我们以此为借口不做任何事情。但我认为这是一个很好的正念思维，那就是：即使带着恐惧的感觉，我依然可以去做这件事。感到害怕不应该成为任何人不做某事的理由。你可以一边感到害怕，一边直接去做。是的。
And trust me, you'll feel. feel a million bucks after you do it no matter what it is. I love that saying. Do it scared. I think it's honestly a beautiful representation for this episode. Okay, I said I had no more questions, but we'll find a question. I have to ask this question. Just because this came to my mind, what is like the favorite thing that you guys are selling
相信我，不管是什么事，做完之后你会感觉超赞的。我太喜欢这句话了。带着恐惧去做。老实说，我认为这完美契合了本期节目的精神。好吧，我说过没有问题了，但我们会找出个问题来。我必须问这个问题。就因为我突然想到了这个，你们现在最喜欢卖的东西是什么？
right now? What's your favorite product that you guys have at fake? Ooh. I would say our downtown pants, which don't look at mine today because I've gotten so dirty today. Sydney is a dirty city. Yeah, I've got like sandwich and something else. some black stuff from Australia Post for me. But I would say it's our downtown pants. They are a, they're kind of made of like a blazer material and they're like your stock standard,
你们在 Fate 推出的最喜欢的单品是什么？哦。我会说是我们的 downtown 裤，不过今天别看我的，因为我今天弄得太脏了。悉尼是个脏兮兮的城市。是的，我身上沾了三明治和别的什么东西。还有澳大利亚邮政的一些黑色杂物。不过我会说是我们的 downtown 裤。它们是一种，有点像西装面料的材质，它们就像是那种标准库存、
like a dressy kind of corporate pant. We have been making our downtown pants for maybe, I want to say three years now or maybe three to four years and they've only gained popularity in the last 12 months. So it's like a style that people have finally realized like these are the best pants ever. We've done them in like 18 different colors. And they've got like a little elastic on the back. So they're really comfortable. And they're just like a pair of pants that you can like wear to work to the office, but then also like fully dress them up with some heels and wear them out at night. So I'd say it's probably our downtown pants. But our best selling category is denim. Yeah, I will say this is this is what you guys are known for your jeans. Yes. The jeans are,
那种偏正式的职场裤。我们制作 downtown 裤大概有，我想说三年了，或者说三到四年了，它们在过去 12 个月里才真正流行起来。所以这是一种人们终于意识到“这绝对是史上最棒的裤子”的款式。我们推出了大约 18 种不同的颜色。它们的后腰带带有松紧设计。所以它们非常舒适。而且它们就像是一条你可以穿着去上班、去办公室，然后又能搭配高跟鞋彻底打扮一番并在夜间外出的裤子。所以我认为可能就是我们的 downtown 裤。但我们最畅销的品类是牛仔。是的，我得说，这就是你们的标志性产品，你们的牛仔裤。是的。牛仔裤是，
I keep saying iconic. Yeah. We've got a whole new, a whole new denim. range coming out in 2026, which I'm really excited about. I thought our jeans were already really good because we sell so many of them and they have the best reviews ever, but it's about to come out in a whole new level. You know what? I also say this, this is something that's completely, like Levi's jeans. I don't like Levi's jeans and I don't know why I just have to say it. I hate Levi's. There's actually like a massive gap in the market for good denim because when you think of a brand in Australia that is known for their jeans, who is it? Like, probably Levi's or like just jeans.
我一直在说这是标志性的。是的。我们有一个全新的，全新的牛仔系列即将在 2026 年推出，对此我真的非常兴奋。我以为我们的牛仔裤已经相当不错了，因为我们卖出了那么多，而且评价也是史上最好，但它即将迈上一个全新的台阶。你知道吗？我也想说这个，这完全是，就像 Levi's 牛仔裤。我不喜欢 Levi's 牛仔裤，我也不知道为什么，但我就是得说出来。我讨厌 Levi's。实际上，优质牛仔裤市场存在一个巨大的空白，因为当你想起澳大利亚哪个品牌以牛仔裤闻名时，会是谁？比如，可能是 Levi's 或 Just Jeans。
Yeah. But it's like they do, this is like just such a personal vendetta I have against Levi's jeans. I've never worn a pair of Levi's. Great, don't. Like they only, like they just don't fit. I'll have to give you some of our new jeans when they come out. I think I might just order some.
是的。但这就像他们做的，这真是我对 Levi's 牛仔裤纯粹的个人怨恨。我从来没穿过 Levi's。太好了，别穿。它们根本，就是不合身。等我们的新牛仔裤上市时，我得送你几条。我想我可能会直接订购一些。
I already own a pair of your jeans. I actually own two pairs of your jeans. I own like your classic, like straight-liked ones. Billie jeans? Yeah, I think that's what they're called. They're great. I think they're quite. Well, they're about to get a whole lot better.
我已经有一条你们的牛仔裤了。我其实有两条你们的牛仔裤。我拥有那种经典款的直筒裤。比利牛仔裤？对，我想它们就叫这个名字。它们很棒。我觉得它们相当。好吧，它们马上就要变得更好了。
There's a new version of Billy coming out. Oh. We've done like a whole new range. Yeah, we've done a whole new range inspired by our current jeans, but they're just leveled up. Is this coming from fate or Kate? Imagine if you just, dude, maybe you should just launch a whole denim company. Don't, because that was my idea. Really?
全新版本的 Billy 系列即将上市。哦。我们做了一个全新的系列。是的，我们做了一个全新的系列，灵感来自于我们现有的牛仔裤，但它们全面升级了。这是来自 Fate 还是 Kate？想象一下，如果你直接，老兄，也许你该直接创立一家牛仔公司。别这样，因为那本就是我的主意。真的吗？
Yeah. Dang. I've even got a name for it. Sorry. I've got a name for it, but we won't say it on the power. No, don't say it because, no, if somebody does their idea better than you, though, you know. Yeah. And, you know, I think there's room for everyone in business.
对。天哪。我甚至连名字都想好了。不好意思。我连名字都想好了，但我们不能在播客里说。不，千万别说，因为，不，不过要是别人把你的主意做得比你好呢，你知道的。对啊。而且，我认为商业世界里容得下每一个人。
Totally. I want to create Fade's competitor as a social experiment, but every brand can exist together and there's enough customers out there for everyone. And also, I would love to see in 2026 and beyond more businesses coming together and collaborating. Like, I would love to collaborate with a competitor of ours. I'm saying like competitor in quotes. Because like imagine if there's two women's fashion brands that come together and come out
完全同意。我想把 Fate 的竞争对手作为一项社会实验来创建，但每个品牌都可以共存，外面的客户足够多，每个人都有份。而且，我也很想在 2026 年及以后看到更多企业走到一起并开展合作。比如，我很乐意与我们的竞争对手合作。我这里“竞争对手”加了引号。因为想象一下，如果有两个女装品牌走到一起，共同推出
with a collection together, bringing both audiences together to go, well, now we love both of these brands. Like Beck and Bridge and Faked the label. That's like a cool like extended size like formal range. I would love to collaborate with another brand that would be considered our competitor. Like I'm friends with, you know, women that own fashion labels and like I don't see them as competitors. I'm like, we can learn from each other and vent to each other when we're stressed about something. Like we can all exist together. Like we can all win. And it's honestly the best feeling is when you have your competition becomes your community. Yeah. What people want to be, you to have as competition, but come to your community.
一个系列，将双方的受众凝聚在一起，让大家觉得，哇，现在这两个品牌我们都爱。就像 Beck and Bridge 和 Fate the label 一样。那就像是一个很酷的、尺码扩展的正式服装系列。我很乐意与另一个被视为我们竞争对手的品牌合作。就像我和一些拥有时装品牌的女性是朋友，我不把她们视作竞争对手。我觉得，我们可以互相学习，在为某事感到压力时向彼此倾诉。我们完全可以共存。我们都可以取得胜利。说实话，最棒的感觉就是你的竞争对手变成了你的社群。是的。人们希望你把对方当成竞争对手，但你却把对方变成了社群。
Absolutely. That is a very positive message to finish and actually finish this episode on. You sure you don't have one more question? Oh, I have like several more, but we just don't have time. Let us know, should I come back for part two? Yeah, guys. Drop a comment below if you want Britt to come back for a part two. Where can they find you?
绝对是这样。这是一个非常积极的信息，用来为本期节目画上句号并真正收尾。你确定你没有最后一个问题了吗？哦，我还有好几个，但我们实在没时间了。让我们知道，我应该回来录制第二季吗？是的，各位。如果在座各位想让 Britt 回来录制第二季，请在下方留言。他们可以在哪里找到你？
I'll leave a link to fate.com down below, but where else would you like them to find you? On socials, you can just find me, Brittany Saunders. I've got two podcasts. One is called Big Business. And the other one is high scrollers with my bestie Matt, which is just like an absolute piss take. And it's really funny. It's really nice to have that funny, creative outlet. And then we have five stores in Australia.
我会在下方留下 fate.com 的链接，但你还希望他们去哪里找你呢？在社交媒体上，你们可以直接找到我，Brittany Saunders。我有两个播客。一个叫《大生意》（Big Business）。另一个是《高额赌客》（high scrollers），我和我最好的闺蜜 Matt 一起做的，这完全是个恶搞节目，真的超级好笑。拥有这样一个搞笑、富有创意的宣泄出口感觉真的很棒。然后我们在澳大利亚有五家门店。
We've got three in New South Wales, which are in Newcastle where I'm from, Parramatta and Westfield Miranda in Sydney. We've got one in Brisbane, which is in Westfield, Chermside. And then down in Melbourne, we have a boutique in Hawthorne. And that's about it. You can find me on TikTok and all the other stuff. You'll find her. Everywhere. Read my book.
我们在新南威尔士州有三家，分别在我老家纽卡斯尔、帕拉玛塔以及悉尼的威斯特菲尔德米兰达（Westfield Miranda）。我们在布里斯班有一家，位于威斯特菲尔德瑟姆赛德（Westfield Chermside）。然后南下到墨尔本，我们在霍桑（Hawthorn）有一家精品店。差不多就是这样。你们可以在 TikTok 以及其他所有平台上找到我。你们能找到她的。到处都是。去读我的书吧。
Just do whatever. This woman is busy. You can find her. Yeah, you can find me. Well, thank you again for coming on. As always, if you guys enjoyed this episode, leave a five-star review. If you feel cool to do so, make sure that you are subscribed or following us wherever you are listening to the podcast and follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. We've been doing these really cool announcements for each of our guests.
总之怎么都行。这位女士很忙的。你们能找到她的。好的，非常感谢你来做客。和往常一样，如果各位喜欢本期节目，请留下五星好评。如果你愿意的话，请确保在收听播客的任何平台上订阅或关注我们，并在 Instagram 上关注我们 @That Psychology Podcast。我们一直在为每位嘉宾制作这些非常酷的官宣。
And as we kind of come to the end of guest month, we've got some cool ones lined up. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
随着我们迎来嘉宾月的尾声，我们还安排了一些很酷的嘉宾。但直到下一次，请注意安全，保持善良，对自我温柔以待，我们很快很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。我是我的播客《2%》的主持人。
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart
我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神韧性、健身以及培养心理弹性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态破茧成重生。收听《2%》。也就是 TWO%，在 iHeart
Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。在《回顾往昔》（The Look Back at it）播客中。1979 年，对我来说是一个重大时刻。84 年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一期节目中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的年份了。在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾往昔》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《艰难一课》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间关乎黑人群体的经历，进行那些在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你们是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once.
有多少男人穿着一身盔甲？它向世界释放出一个信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难一课》。2023 年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·兰基尼（Michael Ranchini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《被困的爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困的爱》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。这将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的好闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听《闺蜜们》（The Girlfriends）。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。